me and currency was super cool
uh me and wale had a little bit of
issues
uh me and cuddy had did a record we were
cool me and co uh me and charles were
cool i had met ace hood that day
so for the most part i was cool with
everybody though what was that what were
the issues you had with wale
it was just some music stuff like i was
trying to get some music done with him
um
me him and push i was trying to get a
track with us three on it and it just
didn't happen
um so i kind of took offense to that i
was new to the game so i didn't really
understand what was going on i didn't
know how i thought if somebody sent you
a record and you know you guys on the
same level you're coming up you just get
it done but
uh he he was real busy at the time he
couldn't get to it so that was like one
of my first lessons in the industry but
i took it to heart and that's why we
kind of had issues at that time was that
an awkward shoot
it was a very awkward shoe it's very
awkward
um but you know
there was you know darker forces behind
the scenes and
when he kind of realized what was going
on he kind of spun the block and was
like yo my fault you know um i
understand what you was trying to do and
there was people that was in my ear at
the time so you know he apologized and
we kind of got behind it